so we're going to talk about sort of an
entry level clustering approach called
k-means now k-means comes up a lot in
other fields so machine learning uses
k-means quite a lot it's what we call an
unsupervised clustering method often
what you have is a situation where you
have some training data but you already
know what it is and then you try and
teach your network to find the same
thing again so we've got labeled
training data in k-means what we've got
is just some data and we say split that
into three please I'll start by showing
a very simple overview here of how
caimans works if we imagine we've got
some some data if it's grouped up so I'm
going to do some X's here and some X's
here so if we wanted to split this data
up we have no idea about this data to my
eye it looks like there are two clusters
here right partly because I cheated and
drew two clusters but you know so if we
were giving this data which is in two
dimensions to a machine and said cluster
this into two what would it do basically
is a question there's lots of different
approaches k-means is just one of these
approaches I'm going to show you today
it's Cayley like just a variable or yeah
k is a variable we input at the
beginning so if it's two we're going to
split this into two if it's five we're
going to split this into five which will
kind of be over splitting this arguably
but it depends when images come in then
you might imagine splitting it into 256
so we can turn it into a 256-color
palette image as an example okay so the
number of caves is very much dependent
on the situation you're looking at so
how do we do this well what we do is we
have K averages for this data so k-means
that's how it works
so I've got myself a couple of squares
of paper here but I'm going to use with
my mean position so I'm going to have
this as mean position one and this is
mean position two now if I was to
calculate the mean position of all of
this data this one is going to be
somewhere in the middle and what k-means
is going to do is partition this into
two and then calculate the means and
then we partition it based on those
means and try and iteratively work out
where the ideal means should be so let's
start number one over here and let's
start number two over here we want to
partition this data into these groups
it's probably going to put a partition
somewhere around here and maybe this is
going to be in group two so these these
will be decided you know depending on
which their nearest to and so that's our
initial segmentation which is pretty
poor because
put a line straight through the middle
of this data and it's no it's not really
any good but it's a start
and so then what we do is we say what
we've got all of these in Group one so
what is the actual average position of
these and maybe this one's in Group one
as well so it remember moves just down
there a little bit just just tweaks a
little bit now this one it's got quite a
lot of these in it so this is going to
come up a little bit so that's step one
right so we partition them into these
two means and then we move the means a
little bit based on how these new
partitions have formed for now let's
assume we've picked one and two at
random we might talk a bit about how you
initialize them in a minute but for step
two we do the exactly same thing again
so we say well now look the data has
changed somewhat okay so I'm gonna use
my green pen now so maybe these ones are
now closest to one and these ones are
now closest to two so we're getting
there okay so then we reclassify them
and we compute the means again and to
comes up here and one comes a bit down
here and then we do it again and two
comes over here and one comes over here
and gradually we settle on the optimal
mean position for our groups okay and
then what that finally means is we put a
big nice line between these two bits of
data okay which is exactly what we
wanted is it possible they could get it
completely wrong good question yes
so absolutely right so if I was if I was
putting in one and two at random so for
example if I put one and two over here
okay you might imagine a situation where
if we're drawing a line down like this
they're kind of evenly distributed
there's no real pull right away and they
just kind of get stuck there okay so
that could happen all right so often
what we might do is run k-means a few
times with different starting positions
and then pick the best one
okay pick the best one as in each of the
ones in this cluster a nearer to one
than they would be in this situation
what we sometimes do is instead of
picking these at random because you know
if I put over here that's not hugely
helpful it's just going to take longer
to converge on a solution what we
sometimes do is pick two points as our
starting positions so I could pick a
point here and a point here now that's
not going to necessarily completely
solve the problem you know if you pick
really bad points that might be a
problem but on average it's going to
work out okay okay there are other there
are other initialization methods like
Amy's plus plus and things like this you
can read about that do slightly more
complex things but the very general idea
is we have an
guess how to separate our data we
separate it and then we calculate the
Centers of those regions and then we
repeat that process to try and converge
on a good separation and k-means is very
effective you know it's simple really
simple two steps basically move these
points into one of the two classes and
then we compute the means and just do
that over and over again now this is
two-dimensional data x and y but there's
no reason it couldn't be free or for
five dimensional data right which I
can't draw a five dimensional than what
that's called but you know a five
dimensional object here on the paper
I could barely draw a three dimensional
one so but in in an image of course
we've usually got three dimensions RG
and B so what we have is we have one
mean for the red position and one mean
for the blue position and one mean for
the green position and we're trying to
move around these in this color space
trying to find what are the dominant
colors so k-means on an image will not
only tell you which pixels belong to
which of the three classes or four
classes or five classes it'll also tell
you what's the average color of those
classes so then we can simplify our
image so if you wanted to compress an
image for example and change it to say
sixteen colors right then you would just
split it into K clusters where K is 16
and then those dominant colors are what
you're going to pick and it will look
kind of like the original image not
great but you know people are used to
seeing compressed images like this you
know on the Internet so let's look at
some moods and see what it does you
could pick any initial image to do this
to my eye there's maybe three or four
dominant colors here there's green
obviously blue and black and to a lesser
extent white I suppose because of these
clouds or gray what we will do is we
will pick three pixels of random okay
and they will be the initial values for
our means okay so let's imagine I'm
splitting this image into three because
I think maybe there are three dominant
colors so I pick I have three means
instead of just number one I have a two
and a three they get started at random
with random RGB values and I cluster the
whole image into those regions one two
or three
then I recompute these mean values and I
cluster again and I recompute the mean
values in my cluster again and this is
what happens on this image for a K of
three so we've got the black or very
dark green down here like green
gray blue sky so that's done exactly
what we hoped it would do okay it split
the image into three if we start to
increase the amount of classes we can
slowly start to improve the image and
maybe start to get towards what the
original image actually look like this
is eight classes you can see that now
we're starting to see what we were
looking at before there's now a
difference between the cloud in the sky
and quite a lot of difference now on
these bushes here okay and as we go up
it gets better and better now on 256
colors we've had a problem here with
some of these have been put into a weird
cluster but that's just what happens
sometimes with k-means do we initialize
it but you can see that actually the sky
is now looking quite a lot like it did
originally because we've got lots of
different colors that we can represent
it in terms of image processing we might
segment this image to try and find the
dominant objects in this image it's not
hugely helpful because even in even with
a few classes we've got objects all over
place we can't for example pick out the
trees particularly well because the
trees are the same color as a grass and
the same colors as Brees bushes here so
doesn't really help us but it depends on
the image you're using if there was a
red bus and nothing else in the image
was red we could pick that class out
nicely so it depends on the situation
going forward they're a much more
complicated segmentation approach it so
things like super pixels that we can
talk about another time
they're trying group coherent regions of
the image locally so they're bringing
spatial information into it as well
which makes a lot more sense because our
bus isn't going to be distributed in the
red throughout the image is going to be
in a box so we can start to look for
things like that I did
particular implementation in MATLAB
because MATLAB can do this in about five
six lines of code
we can make that available in the
comments so if you want to see the
MATLAB code that does this it uses the
inbuilt k-means function of MATLAB so I
didn't have to work too hard to get it
to work and if you haven't got a MATLAB
license octaver also do this using the
same code so you can have a go